NARRATOR: Edgewood Arsenal,
Chesapeake Bay, Maryland, 1952.
As part of a secret government
program termed Project Penguin,
medical doctor and
psychiatrist Andrija Puharich
set up a special
laboratory where
psychics and military
personnel gathered
to investigate
psychological manipulation
and hallucinogenic drugs.
Perhaps one of the most
compelling and controversial
aspects of Puharich's research
was channeling, which involved
making contact with
non-physical beings
through the use of psychics.
It's very important that
we understand that this was
a serious scientific endeavor.
No candles or holy water,
any of that was used.
Puharich used the Faraday
cage, a copper room
that was especially insulated
according to US Naval standards
that would prohibit mid-level
electromagnetic waves
and electrostatic.
In this Faraday cage
individuals would
relax and allow the mind over
matter signal to take place.
In December, 1952,
Puharich invited
Hindu mystic and
doctor DG Vinod to one
of these channeling sessions.
During the experiment, Vinod
went into a deep trance
and made contact with a group
of entities called The Nine.
At the very
beginning, they just
announced themselves as nine
principles of the universe.
Well, that's pretty
to big to start with,
but nevertheless, they said
they were extraterrestrials.
There were forces from beyond.
The Nine said that they were
an eternal presence that they
had been watching humanity
from the very beginning,
and that they were gods, guides,
and this was what particularly
interested Puharich, the
idea that if they are gods,
they of course have
wisdom and Puharich
wanted to ask for guidance.
The Nine came up with a
number of different messages
involving they're being
guardians for the human race,
creators even.
Puharich, he said
what is your name?
Who are you?
And that was the great
revelation because the being
said, I am Atum, and
Atum was the great father
god of ancient Egypt.
And introducing
not only the nine
principles, but
the Nine Great Gods
or the Ennead of ancient Egypt.
NARRATOR: Is it
possible that Puharich
actually made contact with
the Nine Great Gods of Egypt?
Could this be evidence
of a long standing
federation of extra terrestrials
overseeing earthly affairs?
But if so, just who
were these beings?
Heliopolis, Cairo,
known as the Sun City.
This is one of the
oldest and most
sacred sites of ancient Egypt.
Although mostly
destroyed, an obelisk
remains marking the spot where
the Temple of the Sun god Atum
once stood.
Here, the ancient pharaohs
would connect to the Ennead,
a council of nine
deities who were
said to have brought technology
and knowledge to mankind.
According to
Egyptian hieroglyphs,
consultation with the Ennead
was chief among the pharaoh's
duties and critical to
the success of the nation.